en 2017 il s'imposera désormais comme un
immense progrès pour tous et ce progrès
la france ne devra à la majorité qui l'a
rendu possible le gouvernement
mobilisera par ailleurs 200 millions
d'euros pour l'amélioration du
remboursement des soins dentaires au
premier trimestre 2010 7
et quand certains dans cet hémicycle se
situe dans une perspective de des
remboursements des dépenses de santé
mon gouvernement lui agira à la sab le
mans pour renforcer le droit de nos
concitoyens à se faire soigner
telle est notre combat garantir
l'équilibré des comptes et ouvrir
toujours de nouveau droit protégé les
français
cela passe aussi mesdames et messieurs
les députés par une fonction publique
reconnue et respectée proposé de
supprimer des centaines de milliers de
postes de fonctionnaires en quelques
mois
ces remèdes tout simplement en cause la
capacité de l'état à assumer ses
missions les plus élémentaires service
public c'est le condamner
comment en effet assurer la sécurité des
français avec moins de policiers mois de
gendarmes
comment soigner avec moins de personnel
hospitalier comment garantir l'égalité
des chances avec moins d'enseignants
comment accompagner les enfants
handicapés à l'école avec -
d'auxiliaires de vie scolaire
certes notre fonction publique doit se
réformer
il vous plaît mais elle le fait
d'ailleurs en permanence mais je vous le
dis mesdames et messieurs les députés et
je vous le dis du fond du coeur et avec
conviction
on peut réformer sans abîmer et on peut
moderniser sans détruire
[Applaudissements]